This video is brought to you by Squarespace.
Whether you need a domain or a website or an online store,
make it with Squarespace.
Check out squarespace.com for a free trial.
You can find a link in the description below.
He achieved legendary status amongst Kahneman by pulling off some of the most
outrageous,
brazen and unbelievable the seats in the history of fraud.
By the age of 21 he had impersonated a pan and pilot,
a pediatrics supervising doctor and the lawyer charming everyone.
He maps and bouncing checks bowled over the world.
In this week's biographics,
we take a look at the incredible story of Frank William Abignail.
Yeah.
Franconia Maddock nail was born on April the 27th of 1948 in new Rochelle,
New York named after his father who owned a stationary business.
Frank was the third of four children.
His mother Paul,
that was a French Algerian extraction.
If a couple of mats,
while Frank [inaudible] was on active service in Algeria is during World War II.
They were soon married despite a 13 year age gap.
Frank senior proved to be a very successful businessman with the station.
Restore doing exceptionally well as a result of the family lived in a large home
and although the attic now as we're by no means rich frank jr and his siblings
had a comfortable childhood
frankincense did on your new Catholic school in Westchester,
New York,
and there's world was turned upside down in 1960 when his parents separated this
claim as a shock to all the children.
He thought that their mother was a contented housewife who has everything she
ever wanted.
However,
Frank Sr was active in local politics.
He was active in the management of the New York Yacht club and he also was a
very keen,
deep sea fishermen.
All of these interests meant that he was often away from home.
One day he came home from an overseas marlin fishing adventure to find that his
wife and kids that's simply moved out.
Frank Sr,
he was crushed by the separation.
He deeply loved his wife and fought to get her back until the day that he died.
The pullouts mines,
it was made up as a sign of independence.
She enrolled in dental college and began building a life of our own.
Frank Sr.
He recruited junior to help him win back Paul.
That's affections.
He would give his son gifts to pass on schooling him on what to say and how to
say it,
but Paul ass,
she wouldn't budge.
The couple divorced when frank was only 14
unlike your siblings frank chose,
do you live with his father?
This opens up a whole new world for the teenager who had been used to a regimen
and disciplines life with his mother.
Tagging along with his dad.
He began spending time in the bars around New York is frank senior wheeled and
dealed amongst the cities,
businessmen and politicians.
They experience it quickly made the boy very streetwise.
It was around this time frank began to skip school in order to run with a
handful of local punk scene where like him from dysfunctional families and they
were looking for some way to express their frustrations.
Frank,
who is bigger and more mature looking than as associates,
which was handy when it came to playing hooky.
He was often mistaken for a teacher on an outing with his students.
The group committed minor crimes like sneaking into movie theaters and stealing
candy.
Frank soon became frustrated with the childishness and his lack of
sophistication of his partners in crime that they did not exhibit any of the
costs that he realized was key to making it as a successful criminal.
Things came to a head when his friends stole a car while the owner was watering
his lawn.
They swung by to pick up.
Franco needs to be stopped by the police.
Moments later,
frank and his fellow cons web thrown into juvenile detention,
frank seniors,
political connections,
they managed to get his son sprung to have any mention of the incidents and
raised from the rack art.
Frank's down at told him that he was wasting his time hanging around with kids
who were clearly not as mature or as sophisticated as he was.
It was time to start acting like a man.
His father set this pep talk.
It seems to do the trick and frank began attending school regularly.
He also got a part time job as a shipping clerk at a warehouse and Bronxville to
show his support for his son's change of direction.
Frank Sr bought him his first car,
an old Ford.
Okay.
Having a set of wheels opens up new horizons for Frank Specifically,
it allowed him to meet and enjoy the company of women the next couple of years.
By his own admission,
he was consumed with satisfying his teenage libido.
He would cruise around town looking for a young lady that he could entice with
this ever growing chime into an evening of intimate activity.
Frank soon discovered that his sexual excursions,
they cost money.
Invariably it after you supply his conquest with a coconut Berger in order to
keep her happy.
They're all the ones that his mega finances did not allow for such an expense.
Frank approached his dad's and requested a gas charge card.
He promised that he wouldn't abuse this privilege and his father was impressed
with his sincerity.
He handed over his mobile card.
Soon after I'm on filets up.
Frank in access his fest scam bleed into a Mobil gas station.
He saw a sign announcing that you can put a new set of tires on your car and
charge it to your mobile cart.
It was then that he realized that you could use the cart for other things aside
from gas thinking fast.
He approached in attendance at the station that he was familiar with.
Frank asked what it would cost for a new set of tires,
and the answer was $160 frank readily acknowledged that he didn't need new
tires,
but said that he was desperately short of cash,
so he suggested that he buy the set of tires and charged them to the conduit.
Rather than taking the tires,
the attendant would give frank $100 for them.
He could then sell off the tires for $160 making a quick $60 profit.
10 minutes later at frank drove away from the mobile station with $100 cash in
pocket and it was that which looked him over the next few weeks,
frank replicated the scheme of different mobile stations around the Bronx.
At times he would simplify the deal offering the pump attendant.
Do you give him $10 of cash?
Well,
signing a bill for $20 of gas.
It was only when the bill from mobile arrived that frank realized that his
father was the chump who would pay for his excesses.
But Frank,
yeah,
to simple solution.
He threw the bills into the waistband.
Of course,
though that wasn't a solution at all.
It didn't solve anything.
Pretty soon,
a mobile representative visited frank senior at his store and requested an
explanation for an outstanding 3000 or $400 bill in three months.
After 15 years of impeccable payment history,
frank jr when he was called in,
friends of both men to explain,
he said he didn't know what they were talking about,
but neither man was convinced.
Finally,
frank admitted is offering this excuse.
It's the girls that they do funny things to me.
I can't explain it.
His father nodded with a wry smile and replies,
don't worry about it by Einstein.
Couldn't understand it either.
Unfortunately,
for young frank,
his mother wasn't so understanding.
She blamed his criminal activity on the influence of his father,
promised him the organized for him to attend a Catholic private school for
problem children.
Frank spent a year that and during those 12 months his father's financial
fortunes took a steep reverse and he lost almost everything.
He was quick to assure his son that the $3,400 that he had stolen was not a
factor in his money problems.
Frank left home at 16 he left without saying a word to anyone,
hopping on a train to New York City along with the few belongings that he had
crammed into a suitcase he has in his possession of checkbook that had $200 in
the account,
an hour off the train.
He had attached himself to a teenage boy and convinced him to take him home with
them.
Frank wins on to spin a story about being an orphan and that he was determined
to make it on his own and the big city.
The parents said that he could stay for as long as he wanted.
The next day,
frank got a job as a stock clerk for $1 and 50 cents per hour.
He quickly found out that this was not going to pay his way in New York.
He they that the reason for his low wage was his age.
So he simply alter the date on his driver's license from 1948 to 1938 now,
as a 26 year olds,
he went out and looking for another job and he found one as a truck,
driver's helper for $2 and 75 cents an hour.
Brang supplemented his income by cashing checks from his account.
After a few days,
he knew that his account was overdrawn,
but that technicality did not phase him.
He continued writing bad checks on a daily basis.
It didn't take him long to rationalize that his time working for $2 and 75 cents
an hour was simply not worth the effort.
Therefore,
he quit and simply route more bad checks.
One day while walking along 42nd street,
frank was stopped in his tracks,
uh,
beside of an air crew from eastern airlines emerging from the Commodore Hotel.
He was mesmerized as the captain copilots flight engineer in four stewardesses
breezed by frank,
arose in his memoir that he had never seen such a splendid group of people is,
mind's,
begins work over time.
Imagine if he was a pilot.
He was half instant respects and as a result he would be able to cash checks
anywhere with impunity continuing down the street.
He found himself outside of the Pan Am building quickly.
He formulated a plan.
He returned to his accommodation,
found Pan Am's phone number rang and asked to speak to someone in the purchasing
departments.
He went on to inform the purchasing officer that he was a pan and pilots based
in Los Angeles.
He was due to hopper flies back home at 8:00 PM but his uniform had been stolen.
You confidently requested a replacement uniform.
They helpful purchasing officer,
gave frank directions to the uniform company to pick up his uniform.
He walked out with a complete copilots uniform and hands.
What do you needed now as a pilot's ID card?
You quickly,
you had one made up or fixing the Pan Am logo from a model play in the dia
purchased for $2 and 49 cents.
Dax out in his pilot uniform,
frank walked in to Laguardia Airport.
He was soon approached by a TWA pilot who bossed white Pan Am was doing at
Laguardia.
It turns out that pan did not fly out of Laguardia Bucking up on his research.
Frank Replies,
Oh,
I just dead headed in from Frisco on the first flight.
I could cash.
I'll cassia tropic to Kennedy.
The answers seem to satisfy,
but then the copilot asked,
what kind of equipment do you want this?
Through frank and his research,
he hadn't come across the word equipment used in any context searching for the
right answer.
He came out with General Electric.
The pilot was actually asking what type of clean frank flew,
so the quizzical look on his face that this reply was rather understandable.
Frank quickly meters departure.
He didn't attempt to do border blame that first day.
He was disbanded some weeks getting confidence in his role as he wanted.
The airport struck up conversations with pilots and built his store of shop
knowledge.
During this time.
He also found great success and cashing checks and his pilot's uniform.
In fact,
the tellers,
they couldn't give him cash fast enough.
Finally ready to take to the skies.
Frank turned up at the Guardian is eastern operations office and informs the
desk clerk that he needed to deadhead to Miami on the next flight.
Assuming that that was really,
I'm on the plane and heading was the name used for the practice of allowing
staff to travel for free in order to get to a job location.
He was told there was a vacancy on a flight departing in 15 minutes.
Just a few moments later,
he found himself in the cockpit in a tiny seeds that came down from the door
behind him with them where the pilots copilots and flight attendants.
Well,
if you're asking what type of equipment he flew,
the three pretty much ignored him for the rest of the flight.
Before getting off at Miami,
frank made a date with one of the stewardesses who was laying over in Miami that
night.
Amazed how simple the whole process had been.
Frank became a serial dead header.
Upon arriving in a city,
he would stay overnight in a motel used by pan and staff is challenge to the
bills of the company and in the morning before heading to his next debt,
had flight a bad check for $100 or more just to have some ready cash.
This Pason continued for the next two years between the ages of 16 and 18 taking
him to 26 countries on more than 250 flights that covered in excess of a million
miles.
Okay.
By the middle of 1966 frank was ready for a new gig.
He had experienced a close call when someone had stated that he didn't actually
work for Pan out.
Fortunately,
his bluster and feigned outrage got in through the challenge,
but he knew that eventually the game was going to be up.
It was when applying for a long term lease on an apartment in Atlanta,
Georgia that he bought on a whim,
wrote down his profession as medical doctor.
When asked what type of doctorate he was,
he replied that he was a pediatrician based in California,
but it was on a 12 month sabbatical to audit some research papers.
Things went well for a period of time and so one day he'd got a knock at the
door.
Here's new neighbor,
introduced himself real a screenshot doctor with a stranger,
chief resident pediatrician at the Smith as General Hospital in Marietta.
Frank was afraid that Granger would blow his cover,
but fortunately the real doctor wasn't one to talk sharpens they were able to
cross each other's paths without incidents.
Meanwhile,
frank spent as much time as he could at the local library reading up on the
subject of pediatrics.
A few weeks later,
frank felt confidence enough to accept an offer from Dr. Green Jyoti Toss
Smithers general hospital.
After that,
he made regular visits on one subjugation.
He was approached by the hospital administrator and to to do a huge favor could
he cover a midnight to eight shift for a doctor.
He would be away for 10 days due to a death in the family.
Frank objected that he didn't have a license to practice in Georgia,
but the administrator countered that he really wouldn't be doing anything during
the night shift just overseeing the interns and nurses.
So long as he passed an interview panel of five doctors,
everything would be just fine.
Franklin initial impulse was to refuse.
They weren't too many dangers involved in,
but he was intrigued with a challenge and so he agreed much to Frank's early.
If the interview was lighthearted and non inquisitorial,
he was now a night shift.
Pediatric supervising doctor,
we've eight enzymes and 40 nurses under his control.
In order to make it through you,
frank took on the pest side under of a rule of breaking antiestablishment
practitioner in the moles of Hawkeye Pierce on his favorite TV show,
mash things went smoothly until he was called to the emergency room.
He took his time getting that,
hoping that an intern would step in.
When he finally arrived,
there were three enzymes gathered around the patient,
Frank Austin for their diagnoses and twin.
All three agreed.
He told them to go ahead with the procedure at the end of his 10 days stints.
Frank was approached by the administrator in informs that the doctor he was
replacing was not coming back.
It was asked if he could stay on until a replacement could be found.
He ended up spending 11 months as a doctor at Smithers hospital.
I'll have to finishing up at the hospital.
Frank decided to leave Atlanta.
He moved to Baton Rouge,
Louisiana,
where he mess up with a flight steward that he had formerly had a relationship
with remembering the frank consoles error about his supposed law degree from
Harvard.
The girl introduced him at a party to assistant state's attorney,
Jason Wilcox,
on learning,
but frank was currently out of work.
Wilcox told him that the attorney general was looking for bright,
articulate young lawyers.
He suggested the frank take the bar exam and go to practice with them.
Once again.
Frank found it impossible to resist the challenge.
On his third attempt,
he passed the bar exam.
He was given a position in one of the attorney general's civil departments if
the job was really bad of a glorified Aaron's by,
but frank was happy in the anonymity of the role around this time.
He began dating a girl named Gloria,
who was a staunch Methodists three has a relationship.
He ended up on a church committee sitting alongside a man who was a real
graduates of Harvard law school.
This guy began asking too many specific questions and frank knew that it was
time to pull the plug on his legal career.
Frank next turned up in Utah where he claims to have scammed his way into
becoming a teacher at Brigham Young University for eight months.
However,
the university denies that he ever works there.
Why now?
Frank was wanted in many parts of the world for a long list of fraudulent
activities.
The FBI where on his trail as it was in DePaul,
his luck finally ran out while he was spending time in the southern French town
of mantra sharp.
He was arrested on the basis of an instapot warrant for fraud issued from Sweden
for fraudulent checks written during a visit while he was supposedly a Pan Am
employee,
the French authorities,
they soon discovered that he had written false tracks all over that country and
they refuse to honor the extradition.
Frank was sentenced to 12 months imprisonment in France,
which after being reduced to six months,
was served at a perfect non prison.
Conditions were abysmal and Frank's weight went from 198 to 109 pounds during
the stay that he was then extradited to Sweden where he served another six
months upon his release from Malmo prison in Sweden,
frank was taken into custody by US federal officials and returned to the United
States.
After a third trial,
he was convicted do 12 years imprisonment for multiple cases of fraud.
During his time in US custody,
he escaped twice,
but was recaptured on both occasions.
Yeah.
After four years in jail,
frank was offered a deal.
His prison term would be quashed if he agreed to be an uncle consultants to
assist the authorities to investigate fraud cases.
Frank,
he agreed.
After his release from prison,
he took on a succession of menial jobs,
any to be fired for not revealing his criminal past.
He then decided to parlay his vast criminal experience into a legitimate career
by becoming a security consultant and advising companies on how they could avoid
the sorts of scams,
but he had perpetuated for so long.
He went on to set up his own fraud protection company Abignail and he has been
advising the FBI on fraud related matters for more than 40 years.
Frank Guy,
big nail,
age 70 in 2018 lives in Charleston,
South Carolina with his wife Kelly.
They have three sons,
one of whom works for the FBI.
Now in today's video,
you learned all about the identities that frank abignail took on over the years,
but you know what establishes a strong ends,
legitimate identity these days,
a beautiful personal website and do.
You can do that with Squarespace.
Squarespace allows you to create a powerful online identity.
Maybe you're like me and you need to place on the web for people to find you,
or maybe you're starting a new business and you need to set up an online
presence or a store.
Well,
you can do it all with Squarespace on Squarespace.
It all starts with a stunning templates and with names like pursuit and Royce,
you know they've got to be cool seriously.
They are actually very good looking and cool.
So do check them out or if you hate beautiful templates,
not judging here,
you can start from scratch.
Squarespace make it super easy to make something that looks amazing.
You can also easily move over an existing domain and if you've hosted a website
anywhere else,
you know that's a good idea because generally sucks.
It's a lot easier.
In fact,
it's great if you go with Squarespace and once you've gone through the super
easy customization process,
there are no updates,
no patches,
no tag bs to deal with.
No one likes tech,
but yes,
but you know what everyone does like that would be Squarespace is 24 seven
customer support.
They're there to help you whenever you've got a question and square space.
It's not just about an online presence.
As I said,
if you're starting a business and wants to sell online,
Squarespace,
great place to do it.
Like if you're looking to pursue a dream or anything like that,
you need a website and you can do that with Squarespace.
There's no better way.
Had to squarespace.com for a free trial.
And when you're ready to launch,
go to squarespace.com forward slash and bio graphics to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain.
Thanks to Squarespace for sponsoring this video.
Do subscribe to this channel for more biographies every Monday and every
Thursday.
Also hit that like button if you liked it.
And I see in the next video.